on count one of this indictment I
sentence you to a term of six years two
months imprisonment
on count two to eight I sentenced you to
concurrent terms of seven years
but those terms will be served
consecutively to your sentence on count
one
making a total term of 13 years two
months
the time you have served in custody
reparable to these offenses will count
towards your sentence
that will include both the time spent on
remand in this country
and the 10 days I certify you spent in
custody in Germany awaiting extradition
if you serve your sentence in the United
Kingdom you will be released after you
have served half of that sentence you
will then be on license until the expiry
of the total term
if you breach the terms of your license
you can be returned to serve the
remainder of your sentence in custody
serve your sentence in Germany their
rules on early release will apply to you
it is not for me to decide where your
sentence will be served
the surcharge will apply in this case in
the usual amount
I make no orders for confiscation or
destruction of your computer and other
equipment used in this offending as it
is in Germany
if you do not voluntarily relinquish
your rights in it it will be for the
German courts to consider any further
applications
you can take him down